hmm but no French letter without the
condom
the sexist bathroom but every time I
gave him a baby cries it's so fab
strange
praise abort is the first song released
from till Lindemann side project the
Rammstein frontman is teaming up with
swedish guitarist and producer peter
Tecton
the song about abortion is polarizing we
spoke to Rammstein experts seen on
anthology of ski from the Berlin radio
station star fm the clip up nice it was
really surprised by the video had some
pretty shocking elements but you have to
laugh too
you don't know if he's being serious or
he just wants you to feel uncomfortable
listen shame what's a novel one way or
another it gets under your skin you all
done they got even wiser the video is
watched on YouTube over a million times
in less than a week that's not that was
that's got a lot to do with their arm
stein connection tells the frontman of
Rammstein the most successful band in
germany and massively popular all over
the world so there's great interest in
his new project everyone wants to see
what he'll do now that he's branching
out this video is interesting it's
controversial but it's also very
artistic from ahaab runs done like state
court controversy and it's a tactic that
has sold the Moga 16 million albums all
around the world
[Music]
inspired by a true story of cannibalism
that hit the headlines in Germany one
2004 single was so controversial that
the video was only allowed to be shown
in Germany at night
[Music]
this x-rated single from 2009 was pants
censored and it premiered on a porn
channel the front one stays true to his
provocative persona with his latest
video you think David I think he'll
wants to shock us but also to entertain
us he's trying to separate the wheat
from the chaff
my guess is he enjoys taking us on a
roller coaster of reactions once in
vixen be da dairy food at Siddhartha
[Music]
till Lindemann isn't the only member of
the band spreading his wings guitarist
featured Kasbah founded the band
emigrate in 2005 when Rammstein was
taking a creative break emigrate second
album was released last year
[Applause]
meanwhile keyboardist flake Logan's
published a book in Germany earlier this
year it's loosely based on his own life
I have six kids and I don't like it
now the Rammstein frontman is taking
time out
this time he's singing in English
instead of German label draw if you give
one them they bite off balls
let's finish respond I'm interested to
see how tilden demands new project is
received I think it's the most
interesting of the vom Stein project so
far it's the most artistic and most
profound
Linderman's new single is rocking the
boat ahead of the new album release on
June the 19th its title track has called
skills and pills and lists all the meds
that till Lindemann takes and there are
more controversial tracks on the album
too fans and haters can look forward to
songs entitled golden shower or [ __ ]
found to be both loved and loathed
you